هنا في مدرسه الفخوره والتي كانت تاوي
الاف الاف النازحين من مناطق بيت حنون
ومناطق
بلايا حيث اصبحت
خرابا بعد ان كانت تاوي الالاف الالاف
المؤلفه من النازحين عشرات بل مئات من
الشهداء بل مئات من الشهداء الليله قضوا
في هذه المدرسه بعد قصف واستهداف قوات
الاحتلال الصهيوني
للفصول
يمكن ان نشاهد
هنا القصف الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف الفصول
الامنه والتي كانت تاوي نازحين والجميع
يعلم من هم بداخل هذه المدرسه والان نسمع
القصف في مجاور هذا المكان هنا حيث نزح
المواطنون نزوحا اخر الى المستشفيات
ومدارس اخرى بعد استهدافهم
وقصهم من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الليله كان هناك حزاما ناريا في هذه
المنطقه والكثير والكثير من القذائف هنا
حيث مشاهد صعبه هنا من مكان
استهداف هذه المدرسه هذه مقتنيات النازحين
في
المنطقه هنا حيث الدماء والاشلاء